what's up y'all this is Kelly Clarkson
here just hanging out with BuzzFeed and
what I'm about to do is gonna blow your
mind you're welcome this is the Kelly
Clarkson discography challenge bracket
much like the March Madness bracket
except this one matters I'm just kidding
haha first up behind these hazel eyes
and since you've been gone I'm gonna go
with hazel eyes I just I don't know I
love the video I love seeing that song
stronger and never again I'm gonna stay
stronger I mean I like never again but
stronger is such a fun song to sing and
just so many cool stories people tell me
of why they relate to that song I really
love that one cuz if anyone's relating
never again they've had a really crap
relationship so my life would suck
without you or dark side dark side
basically I'm just picking any song a
particular person isn't a part of loves
too soft a whole lot of woman that is
hard I'm gonna say a whole lot of woman
because I refer to Texas so why wouldn't
I
I do not hook up or walk away I'm gonna
say walk away I love that bridge it's my
favorite miss independent or mr.
know-it-all I'm just you know what miss
independent still after 16 years is
literally my favorite song to perform
it's weird a whole lot of woman is to a
close tie but all I ever wanted to let
me down woo let me down I am angry I
love angry Kelly with music I did just
talk about myself that person heat or
heartbeat song I have to go the
heartbeat song cuz it's my my youngest
daughter's favorite and she's so cute
she loves to sing it all the time hazel
eyes and stronger I'm gonna go stronger
it's just a really cool message I like
an empowering message if you've sensed
that theme over the last 16 years okay
darkside or a whole lot of woman a whole
lot of woman walk away or miss
independent I don't know I'm gonna say
walk away that was tough and that was
like Gargan Zola whatever that team is
you know the really good one go ho dozen
guns Agha Gonzaga
it was Gonzaga sports ball yay let me
down or heartbeat okay I love my little
girl
and I know that like all fans probably
owe me to pick heartbeat song but I love
let me down I was actually very mad
in the parking lot of a yoga studio
where I chose to write a song instead of
doing yoga I generally choose to do most
things other than working out stronger
or a whole lot a woman a whole lot of
woman I know plenty are disagreeing I
don't care it's mine it's my bracket you
make your own walk away or let me down
gonna have to go with walk away though
love walk away it's just fun to sing and
there's horns and it's fun and I just
feel like it's the closest I get to
being cool like Annie Lennox and my
discography so whole lot a woman or walk
away I'm choosing all that a woman
already gone or sober hands down sober I
love sober cry nice or don't you want to
stay oh don't you want to stay it
reminds me of like a country ballad like
from like the 90s I mean well it reminds
me of a country alex is a country ballad
i meant specifically from the 90s
because of you or piece by piece piece
by piece because it's like I feel like
they're bookends and the first one's
just a real sad bookend and at least the
second one you know piece by piece is
redeeming towards the end because of you
is just like a Dateline special nothing
happy happens there haunted or Irvine
that is a throwback it's the saddest
song I've ever written but I'm gonna go
with every wine it was a rough day in
Irvine a moment like this or break away
really any other song I love that you
put these two together okay neither they
both just lost the game um I'm gonna say
break away The Sun will rise or catch my
breath I'm gonna say catch my breath I
got to write that with Jason Halbert and
I love him my entire career would not
have been possible without Jason Halbert
wrapped in red or underneath the tree oh
the imagery of wrapped in red but I'm
gonna Santa Neath the tree you just want
a big uplifting song that you can dance
to it right Christmas Eve or winter
dream brain and so on
no-brainer brain and song so sober and
don't you want to stay I'm gonna say
sober I love the song but I really love
sober it was a really sad time I needed
to get that message out piece by piece
or Irvine I'm gonna say piece by piece
break where you catch my breath
underneath the tree or winter dreams
gonna have to go Thunder Neath the tree
on this one I do love winner dreams it
sounds like what a snow globe would
sound like if it had a sound but I'm
gonna have to go with underneath the
tree
okay sober or peace
Pease gonna have to say so berm letting
a lot of people down here I don't care
catch my breath or underneath the tree I
love Christmas underneath the tree sober
or underneath the tree I'm gonna say
sober because I feel like you only get
underneath the tree it's only
appropriate it's not appropriate in June
right
Sobers appropriate any time of the year
okay so a whole lot of woman or sober
those are two different moods it's like
really basically what we've just done is
we're picking between my 20s and my 30s
totally gonna go with my favorite whole
lot of woman cuz sober was a very sad
place for me hold on a woman that's the
winner you know why cuz I am your
welcome for all of it Kelly Clarkson
discography challenge bracket I don't
care if you don't like mine do your own
bye I said gorgonzola remember their
name